the topic of ufos and alien visitation
of planet earth is at an all-time high
and to be fair more people than not
think that aliens are visiting earth or
have at some point in the past however
nothing is certain but when we see
articles with the pentagon officially
releasing actual videos of
unexplained aerial phenomena
this has people asking questions in fact
we even have nasa allegedly joining the
hunt for ufos however if you were to ask
me how could he not have always been
doing this as if astronauts and other
types of technology orbiting the earth
haven't been doing so already i mean
come on now many people have asked me
what my thoughts are on this and i have
quite a few things to say in fact to be
blunt
yes i do think that aliens have been
visiting earth however i think that it's
been happening for a very very long time
and as i've shared in videos a few years
ago
if you look at some of the earliest
tablets from human civilization that
date back to ancient mesopotamia or the
birthplace or cradle of civilization
you see some very bizarre images i mean
just look at this it appears that there
are three beings on some sort of aerial
craft in the shape of a bird or hawk or
eagle
with gentlemen down below a seemingly
greeting them now you could say oh this
is simply just honoring the gods or that
these are angels or something to that
effect but i mean like i always say look
and think for yourself i mean it has
long been argued that the sumerians have
had advanced knowledge of our solar
system that far exceeds the known
capabilities of five and six thousand
years ago i mean if you ask me it seems
that they knew or understood that we had
planets orbiting around the sun
however not everyone will agree with
this and think or say that they're
simply just stars
this is something that cannot be known
for sure
but again look and think for yourself
now
when i bring up the sumerians and the
assyrians
look at these bizarre sea creatures that
you find in multiple depictions
this brings up the recent articles
involving these alleged ufos that have
been witnessed by the united states
military for having dove down into the
ocean and disappearing now let's be real
if there was one place for someone or
anything to hide on planet earth it'd be
at the bottom of the ocean particularly
around places like say the mid-atlantic
ridge that's a vast mountain system one
of the biggest on earth and there could
be cave systems under there that we
would have no way of knowing especially
being several miles down
now when i look at these images that
date back so many thousands of years
could they be depicting that beings had
come from the ocean and attempted to
gift us things after all the sumerians
do claim that beings had come down and
gave us advanced knowledge
however this is all subject to debate
but there are some very bizarre
paintings and other artwork that date
back several hundred years
that show some things that might make
you think so
this painting also known as the madonna
this dates back to the 1400s and when
you look to a bizarre detail in the
upper right hand corner this is
something that many people were not
aware of until just the last several
years
what you see is a gentleman and his dog
literally peering up into some sort of
craft
and i mean come on like i always say
look and think for yourself and i can't
say it enough because there's different
ways of interpreting this and it must be
said that the painter it's not exactly
known why he painted this this is
subject to debate it's not widely
documented and nothing is known for sure
however to be clear
scientists and historians do not think
for one second that this could possibly
be an alien spacecraft of any kind
but again when i look at this it's just
truly bizarre now
many people have seen this painting
before however there are other ones that
are lesser known
this painting here known as the
crucifixion of christ from the 1350s is
on a mural in spain or excuse me
actually kosovo
but when you look in the upper right and
left-hand corners you see two bizarre
images that have beings in these
flying crafts that's well just look
now let's be clear this is said to be
this uh the sun and the moon
but
i mean when i look at this i can't help
but think that we're witnessing
something different now again i'm not
convinced of anything sure yeah maybe
this is just the sun and just the moon
but it is truly bizarre
and
like i said that involves the
crucifixion of christ and this dates
back 700 years ago and when you look at
other images of christ
you will notice that these are not the
only images that have
so-called ufos in them for example the
miracle of the snow which again dates
back to the 1400s
look at this and tell me what you see i
mean it's well it stands out you see
many craft
or possible craft and i mean you see
these people down below just
worshiping or doing whatever i mean
i don't know guys i look at this and
those do look like flying saucers let's
be real now again this is not proof that
they are flying saucers however
speaking of christ and now the baptism
this image dates back to the early 1700s
and it's of the birth of christ and what
you see is this
thing up in the sky shining four beams
of light down now some people will say
this may represent the three wise men in
some capacity or you know blessing of
angels and god
but it is a bizarre painting from the
early 1700s but let's move along to
something else that i think is even more
interesting and this one is called the
annunciation with saint emedius and this
is again from the 1400s what you see
here is some things going on in the
streets and this
beam of circular lights beaming down
into this home or
wherever it is into this woman and the
beam with the dove a seemingly going
into her head and this could have so
many different types of interpretation
this could be again the announcing that
mary had the angel been visited gabriel
and the holy spirit and there's
different things you can read up on this
and one thing i've noticed is that if
you read things in different places
you'll hear different answers so again
not to be redundant but i always say
look and think for yourself again this
does not prove at all that there was
some sort of alien visitation giving
this woman knowledge or whatever else
but it's a bizarre painting i mean look
at the sky what's happening here you
have these other people down below on
the street
i don't know it's just weird and it's
fascinating and this is a particular
image that many people have never seen
or heard of before now
the next image i'm a little bit more
skeptical of this dates to israel in the
1600s there's not a whole lot known
about it to be honest
but what you see is this home
with this
again possible flying saucer
and
this is on a tapestry it's not the best
image
and again since so little is known about
it it's hard for me to even really say
anything about it definitively
again it's just strange and it's worth
sharing now
if we move on to the other side of the
world to peru you will notice what's
called the nasco lines
and or then bolivia excuse me and you
have this being waving to the sky and
this thing is hundreds and hundreds of
feet long it's massive
and it's on a the slide of a hill and
it's facing upwards towards the sky and
it's seemingly waving at someone
that's bizarre everyone knows it it's
unexplainable there's nothing more than
interpretation because we don't
understand who actually did it and why
but again it's bizarre now since we're
in this part of the world i must bring
up king kapaa or pakal and this image
which of course has been seen by many
people as some ancient astronaut
theorists will say hey look this guy's
on an alien spacecraft of some kind it's
like a jet he's operating it almost like
a motorcycle and it's clearly a craft to
take you somewhere
now
this let me first say that this is on
the lid of this king's sarcophagus and
to be fair every image that you'll see
in depiction of this king piccal
is weird he's green he looks odd it's
strange in every bit in every way
however you can look into different
interpretations of this again in my own
view this is something that nobody can
fully explain
it's obviously bizarre i'm very
open-minded to it i'm not convinced one
way or the other and perhaps you
shouldn't be either
but if there was some way if we were to
ever excavate and find some sort of
craft that looked like this and all of a
sudden everyone would be like well see
it was so obvious and no one wanted to
hear it right
so
now that being said i've discussed and
you might recognize my church as a word
in this last video from a couple years
ago where i discussed what's called
transient lunar phenomena where lights
have been seen on the moon from earth
over the last 1500 years in fact there's
more than 1500 noted examples even
documented by nasa and and by the way
yes this is a real photo this is from
the university of columbia and this was
taken in 1953
and this is something that's happened
like i said thousands of times over more
than a millennia and these examples are
absolutely fascinating where you'll have
documented cases where red lights have
been seen glowing on the moon for hours
on end and it implies more than anything
else that that would be volcanic
activity but that's not supposed to be
happening on the moon the moon the moon
is supposed to be dead and boring right
go check out this video it's worth your
time i think that there are a number of
details in it that you'll find to be
completely fascinating now with all this
said this is not a topic that i am going
to
not discuss again because there's too
many other examples i mean if you look
at christopher columbus's journey to
america or alleged journey i mean
he didn't discover anything but never
mind that uh he documents in his diary
find that there was an orb following
them like a reddish orb
and guys
when you start to see things yourself or
if you know other people that you find
to be very trustworthy credible family
members whoever and they tell you the
stories that more and more people are
seeing like i my brother and his wife
saw an orb when they're up in the
mountains at a cabin
and it was this orange orb that was
going horizontally quite quickly and all
of a sudden
just shot up to the to space gone like
that
that's not supposed to exist it defies
the laws of physics so something's
happening here the question is is it us
which i do think but the question is
where did we get this advanced
technology that defies the laws of
physics is this something we found is
this something we inherited from beings
that had once visited us long ago or is
this something that's happening right
now by beings that are observing us
because i'll be honest with you i think
that us as humans are such a bizarre
species that it would seem to make sense
that we're hybrids i've discussed this
many times before um it just seems that
we don't assimilate at all in our
environment there's something odd about
us and i i mean if you look at any city
from space it almost looks like a cancer
spot
there's something i mean every other
animal and creature on earth just
assimilates naturally but we don't and
we're a mad species we're like getting
in wars we kill each other for no good
reason most of the time it's it's
it would seem to make sense to me that
when you look at all these different
historical examples or should i say
religious examples of angels demons and
sky gods coming down and creating man in
their image i'm like guys maybe we are
the aliens and this is exactly how they
look
i don't know this is a wild topic to me
it's one of the most fun things to talk
about and i'll be discussing it in
further videos uh my next video is
supposed to be on atlantis as i told
everyone before but there's a few more
tweaks this video needs it's not quite
ready it needs to be a good one and i
want to knock out something really fun
and interesting for you guys to think
about as i finish that one up but
that said leave a comment share what
your thoughts are on all of this and all
these paintings i guarantee it you know
there's people like oh this is totally
explained but
if you can't find documentation of the
actual painter explaining why they
painted these things
which is the case for many things i just
shared with you
to me it's like it's fair game to
discuss and open interpretation because
we already know that there's people that
look at this in two different ways
the aliens have never been here never
were
and other people that are convinced that
they're here right now or you know and
anything else so that being said it's a
fun topic so share your thoughts on it
in the comments but i'm jimmy corsetti
my channel is called bright insight and
look forward to a new uh video on
atlantis coming real soon thank you all
for watching bye now